what's up wisecrack
michael here whether you stan or hate
hamilton you've probably heard about a
little controversy
the founding father themed rap musical
is full of hideous lies
for example hamilton's onstage love
interest angelica skyler
very clearly reps that she had no
brothers
[Music]
and yet she had at least one
[Music]
okay who cares right but it got me
thinking
in every piece of historical fiction
there's got to be some
line between actual fact and necessary
fabrication
and despite the collective eye rolls we
all get when someone chimes in
uh actually skyler was also married when
she met hamilton
this problem raises a pretty important
question does watching historical
fiction
ironically make us dumber about history
or is a musical like hamilton an
important tool to get people to care
about colonial fiscal policy but
hamilton forgets
his plan would have the government
assume states death from hamilton to
bohemian rhapsody to vice to even a game
like assassin's creed
historical fiction is either a great
learning tool that your hungover
substitute teacher can put on with the
lights out
or it's well a horrible crutch used by
said hungover teacher who
really would like to just close their
eyes so what's the deal
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on historical fiction and spoilers ahead
for
true historical events and also stuff
people made up about them
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor our
patrons
but they probably won't see this because
they have access to
all of our videos ad free now if you can
and want to support us you should check
it out
patrons get access to ad-free content
our patron-only discord research
documents for our videos and more
we even throw in unlisted bonuses like
wisecrack hangouts where we stream games
and do q and a's
if that sounds interesting head over to
patreon.com wisecrack
or check out the link in the description
now back to hamilton
alright let's be clear any writer who
wants to condense someone's entire life
story into a few hours of screener stage
time
has to make some hard choices for
example in many biopics it's common for
the writer to combine
several real life people into a single
character or to invent a new character
altogether
to further the plot or make a point if
bombshell invents a generic ambitious
news anchor who's a stand-in for the
many
real women she represents that's not
that bad right
hamilton based on ron chernow's 2004
biography of the man
also has to use some artistic license in
dealing with history
the musical chronicles the political
career of the american founding father
and dope lyricist in his journey from
immigrant orphan
the cousin committed suicide left him
with nothing but ruined pride something
new
the secretary of the treasury along the
way it features an american revolution
a juicy sex scandal and a cast of
hamilton's friends
lovers and enemies maybe because of its
nearly three hour run time the play
manages to avoid many shortcuts that
other biopics have to take
also they rap kind of fast which makes
it easy to jam a lot of information in a
short amount of time
on a british government i take the
measurements information and then i
smuggle it
to my brother's revolutionary confidence
play is also full of a historical
moments like this when john laurens and
pals introduce themselves as if they're
a troupe of subway performers
despite a lack of primary sources on
lafayette's relationship to showtime
hamilton is frequently lauded for its
adherence to historical fact
but when people do quibble it's
generally when hamilton's inventions
meet historical fact at this weird zone
of
wait is this actually true and that
intersection and the resulting confusion
about what isn't isn't true
may very well end up making us feel less
rather than
more informed for instance historians
david waldstriker and jeffrey paisley
argue that the play
is part of a genre of founders chic
painting hamilton and the other founders
in an overly patriotic and positive
light
the storytelling they argue is fueled by
made-up character and personality traits
rather than by the facts in real life
there's a lot of nuance on hamilton's
relation to racial or class issues in
colonial america
but the playwright probably for
clarity's sake chose to skip past that
nuance
instead miranda uses a lot of creative
license when diving into hamilton's
views on slavery
in the play john laurens claims that he
and hamilton write essays against
slavery and later
in yorktown the men insist that until me
and slavery walt striker and paisley see
this as an exaggerated fantasy portrait
of hamilton as a staunch abolitionist
when in reality hamilton wasn't an
anti-slavery activist
in fact he bought and sold slaves for
his in-laws
now this all may be very intentional
since miranda very clearly opted to tell
a story about the very white and very
slave-owning founders through a
predominantly black musical tradition
with a multicultural cast
but these likely deliberate
mischaracterizations are really
important
and can help us understand a bigger
phenomenon something i'm going to call
the uncanny valley of truth in
historical fiction
you probably know of the uncanny valley
it's basically a graph showing how
cute things get as they take on human
characteristics until they get
too human-like and become absolutely
horrifying
but then they get even more human-like
and it's totally fine again
that uncomfortably close to human part
of the graph is the uncanny valley
it's unsettling so sonic the hedgehog is
kinda cute because he's a hedgehog with
a few human elements like walking
upright
talking and wearing gloves but give
sonic some too realistic baby teeth and
holy hell your indian caney valley now
put some steve bushemi eyes on him and
we can see how deep this abyss really is
while no one is getting nightmares about
lin manuel's rap battle
we can see a similar kind of graph in
the truth in fiction
if i were to tell you a story of a time
traveling scott bakula who gets stuck in
a wrestler's body
you'd be like cool that's not real
history on the other hand if i were
instead to show you espn's the last
dance with bakula deep faked under the
body of tony cuckooch you might say
what the [ __ ] is this real did scott
bakula play for the chicago bulls
that's because the latter example lands
somewhere in the uncanny valley of the
truth the part of the scale between
fiction and reality where something
looks close enough to reality to
bewilder an unsuspecting audience
in the case of people complaining about
historical fiction it's the moment where
the line between fake rap battles and
real beliefs between hamilton blur and
become unsettling for
anyone who is paying attention the real
danger of course is that instead of
becoming more informed about historical
events through some light
embellishments people become more
ignorant as they fill their brains with
fiction consumed as truth
you as a casual viewer of hamilton might
have assumed some details to be rooted
in historical fact because
why would they make up the assertion for
instance that thomas jefferson was
absent during most of the war
our guess probably because it made for a
very charming opening song to act
2.
[Applause]
[Music]
now before we start sounding too
curmudgeonly a quick caveat
compared to most historical fiction
miranda's fact-checking is actually
pretty buttoned up
there are far more egregious examples of
writers convincingly changing history
and thereby
very much misleading their audience
still the fact that within miranda's
well-researched story that
so many details are just plain wrong can
feel a little bit
alarming it speaks to the potential
risks of trusting historical fiction
without spending hours fact checking it
afterwards
at the very least it might make you
embarrass yourself on trivia night it's
like everyone gets a point for albert
einstein
oh wait except for the einsteins
nowhere is this more apparent than in
writer director adam mckay's absurdist
biopic vice
which claims to be based on the real
history of dick cheney's tenure as vice
president under george w
bush as such mckay seems pretty
self-aware about the problems of turning
history into a blockbuster film
with that in mind he goes to great
lengths to signpost the fictionalized
parts of the movie
at one point dick and lynn cheney have
an entire conversation in shakespearean
verse
that has honored thy vows to wife and
crown
as if to really drive home the fact that
we made this whole thing up
uncanny valley averted but as journalist
jen williams put it the film as a whole
is about as accurate about cheney and
the iraq war as sharknado is about
sharks and the weather
williams argues that the exclusive focus
on cheney reduces the roles of everyone
else who made decisions in the bush
administration also the film just makes
a lot of things up
one pivotal scene advice set in the
1970s depicts a conversation between
dick cheney and antonin scalia that
seems true to history
only problem it's entirely a work of
fiction
in the scene scalia introduces cheney to
the concept of unitary
executive theory are you familiar with
the theory of the unitary executive
the concept of unitary executive theory
wasn't even around until the 1980s
and according to legal scholars the film
butchers the term interpreting it to
mean that
everything the president does is legal
which is simply
not true in his apparent determination
to paint cheney as a mastermind who is
building a case for unlimited executive
power early in his career
adam mckay dreamed up a fake
conversation this may be compelling when
creating a cogent character arc
vices chaney finally got the unlimited
power he had wanted for so
long but it's simply not based in fact
it's
also implied that dick cheney received
intelligence briefings before the
president did
we will also be receiving the daily
intelligence briefing before
the president that gets us inside the
decision curve this is a magnificent
detail showing cheney's apparent
capacity
to manipulate his presidential boss
george bush unfortunately it seems to be
entirely invented
but there's no shakespeare or absurdism
to indicate this part of the movie's
fiction
by sometimes but not always signposting
what was fake
mckay had inadvertently made the uncanny
valley of truth so
much worse combined with an uncanny
makeup job on christian bale
the presentation had audiences leaving
theaters thinking wow
i can't believe dick cheney did all
those things
and maybe that's exactly what adam mckay
wanted to influence public opinion with
a compelling story
but it had journalists like james mann
sounding the alarm for it being lazy and
irresponsible
even as man argued that the real life
actions of cheney were far
worse filmmakers venture into this
uncanny valley of truth a lot
especially in biopics and period pieces
based on true events
and also whatever the hell this is so
can historical fiction
ever avoid this trap the way information
is communicated and the expectations of
the audience seem to make all the
difference
it seems like some works of historical
fiction can get by without much scrutiny
because it's
clear that they're works of art and not
real are you not entertained
they never venture into that uncanny
valley of truth
or if they do the stakes are pretty low
take for example the favorite jorgos
lanthimos's dark comedy is so
obviously a satire that it would be hard
to mistake it as historically accurate
even though the characters are loosely
based on real people a melodramatic plot
and rapid dialogue
you may have the tapestry budget you
asked for spend one penny more and i
will take your fingernails into you
along with physical comedy
unconventional camera angles and cross
dissolves on bunnies
make it very clear that this stuff
shouldn't be taken as fact
it also helps that there wasn't a block
of text at the top of the film claiming
that it was based on a true story
of course you could claim not to be
based in any fact and actually smuggle
in
real history some historical fiction
centers around completely fake premises
and characters
from period horror like hbo's lovecraft
country to video game series like
assassin's creed
in these works the central characters
are completely made up
and things like monsters and genetic
memory exist but there's still knowledge
to be gleaned from them about how things
work historical accuracy comes through
in things like costume design world
building and general depictions of past
customs
assassins creed unity is a helpful
example set during the french revolution
the game's design was heavily influenced
by archival research and recruited the
help of multiple academic historians
dr jean clement martin consulted on the
script and scholar laurent turco
assisted with the look and feel of 18th
century paris
the resulting virtual model of the city
was so detailed that ubisoft offered to
use the game's digital version of the
notre dame cathedral to help rebuild the
real one after it burned down in 2019
so while the whole traveling into your
ancestors brains and characters are
quite
obviously fiction the experience of
france during the revolution might have
some historical value for players
in hbo's watchmen there was a kind of
reverse uncanny valley where the very
real
tulsa race massacre was dramatized in a
story featuring a blue dude who hangs
dong
many viewers instead of being caught off
guard by a historical fabrication a la
hamilton
were instead caught off guard by a
historical truth
similarly in lovecraft country the
characters and story are entirely a work
of fiction
especially the horrifying monsters still
many of the scenarios the characters
experience
mirror very real experiences of black
americans during jim crow so
hearing the sheriff explain what a sun
downtown is might get people asking
is this true any of you all know where
the sun downtown is
yes sir we do well this is the sundown
county
and then they might google it and now
you have someone who learned something
through the power of fiction
this is all to say just because
something is a fictionalized account of
history
doesn't mean we should knock it for
being all lies it just kind of depends
what the lessons are and how they're
communicated
it also matters how we as an audience
approach the material
but to get back to more cut and dry
historical fiction like hamilton or vice
their problems aren't unique to biopics
or bio
musicals wald striker and paisley
acknowledge a lot of their problems with
miranda's portrait of hamilton
actually came from chernow's
characterization of hamilton and the
biography the musical is based on
it simply dropped the latest version of
founder sheik to a faster beat let's
take a stand with the stamina's
the point is if hamilton the plague can
lose some of the nuance
so can actual written texts of history
the editors of the book historians on
hamilton admit that
history is not simply a matter of facts
but is an
interpretation of the existing archival
record actively constructed by whoever
is serving as the historian
the musical acknowledges that there are
certain things we simply cannot know
indeed there is a whole song about how
we don't really know what went down
between hamilton jefferson and madison
in the room where it happens
this suggests a healthy amount of
self-awareness and another historians on
hamilton essay
joseph adelman stresses that hamilton
makes absolutely no claim to being a
work of scholarly history
and that it resembles a tradition of
historical fiction that's been around
almost as long as the united states he
writes that
almost as soon as the revolutionary war
ended in 1783
americans began to discuss hypothesize
and conjecture
about what the new nation would be in
part by arguing over how it was born
to adelman hamilton is something that's
not entirely
credible historically but is incredibly
accessible to a wide audience as a piece
of historical fiction
which makes it valuable while it's
important for scholars to engage with
and call out its factual errors
there's no denying that hamilton at the
very least
teaches us about how history is
communicated and canonized
and at most gets us excited about
history and i think that has to be worth
something
all i know is that when i die the answer
to
[Music]
so what do you think wisecrack is
historical fiction a useful tool to get
us jazzed about the story of america's
founding in the exhilarating history of
constitutional law
or is it just going to confuse everyone
on their ap history exam
let us know you think in the comments
big thanks to our amazing patrons for
your support
don't throw away your shot at hitting
that subscribe button and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
bye